でマイペースということ
で 各スピードオブインディビジュアルイズインモストケースズディファレント
それは大したことではないんですけど
この個人の時計はスピードは異なっているということで
各個人の だからあなたと私は同じ時間というわけじゃないんです
でないでしょ 結婚なさってるんだからね
結構大変でしょ 奥さんと旦那さんの時間が違うんだから
時計が 私の時間とあなたの時間
個人の妄想 感情 好き嫌い
価値観などは他人と異なっている
したがって 一人一人の自分の時間というものがある
眠っている時間ですよ
妄想して これは人によって違います
各人によって違います
この個人差とかね 世界の一人一人の人間が違いますよ
そこであの例えば神様を信仰している方々は
それを神様はそういうふうに作ったんだから偉いでしょうって言うでしょ
仏教から見れば もう各人がの妄想感情違うんだから
妄想するって遅くなる時間なんですね
時間が違うんです 一人一人それで違うんです
それは一人が妄想に浸す時間なのです
物の流れは普遍的に一定しているが
それに人間が関わると違いが生じる
それは例えばまあ料理しましょうと
まあもう大根もなんとか味噌汁を作って
もうまあ弁当しか食べたことないんだから思い出せませんだけど
料理は あの 何て言いますか
もう味噌汁を作って ご飯を炊いて
また何かなにかおかずを作ると
そうすると 例えばもう品作ると
じゃが肉じゃがとかね
まあ味噌汁とご飯とまた何か言ってください
知らない まあ全く合わないことを言って言ってくれたんですから
まあ食べて まあ肉じゃがと卵焼きとね
まあそれで風呂です で
そうすると まあまあ私には数だけでいいんだから
まあ肉じゃが作る時間
卵焼き作る時間と もう味噌汁とご飯というのはもう決まってますよ
決まってるんだけど 人によってかかる時間違うでしょ
人によってかかる時間違うんです
例えば ある人が先に米を炊いたとする
米を洗って炊飯器に入れて
まあそれから肉じゃがの用意をするとかね
あるいはもう一人はもう米は別に関係なく
まずじゃがいもをなんとかして
もう必要なものはあれやれ揃ってきて
それをまず肉じゃがの料理をして
それはちょうどいいところになってくると
米も炊いておいて で そこで味噌汁の用意をして
それでちょうどいい時間になってくると
もう卵焼きを焼き始めると
そうするともう最後にもうご飯も入れて
あれも入れて これも入れて
最後に今もう焼いたばっかしの卵卵焼きをさっさっさっと一緒に出せるということをできるでしょうし
だから その人の考え方によってかかる時間が違うんですよ
最初にご飯を炊いてきた人が
それから肉じゃが始めちゃうと
ご飯は炊飯器で長い時間置いといちゃったんだから
もしかすると美味しくないかも
随分時間かかるんですよ
だからこの同じ仕事をしても
各人が使う時間違う それはなぜ違うかというと
その人はどれぐらい妄想しているのかって
ただそれだけ 人間同士で何かをしようとすると
うまくいくはずはないんです
だから 二人で 三人で 四人で何かしようとすると
決してまとまれませんよ
だからまとめようとするのはものすごい無理な仕事なんですよ
世界はまとめてないでしょうに
みんなそれぞれバラバラ
だからそれは妄想ということで
はい 次 これだから困ると人にこなせないほどのことをいたくする
それで人にこなせないほどの仕事を我々は頼むでしょうに
これは困りますよ 自分も個人も自分の時間を無視してたくさんことをしようとする
個人個人で自分がどれほど妄想しているものかと忘れているんだからね
はい やります はい やりますと言うでしょ
それたくさん仕事はもらっちゃいますけど
もうできなくなっちゃう
だからこれで困りますよ
それだから 世間の状況も個人の時間も無視してノルマをかける
もうかけられちゃうでしょ
時々 会社で社長が課長が好き勝手にそんなことかけちゃっても
世界経済というものもありますからね
社会状況というものもありますからね
役立たない品物を作って
これはもう 40個売ってくださいとかね
これ 100軒歩いたっても一個も売れないとかね
それであんたはもうちゃんと頑張ってない
もうやる気が足らんだ
あれやこれやという これで困るでしょうに
ということで 競争昇格
表彰 賞金などの人参を見せて脅す
そんなのは人参ですよ
その人参見せちゃうと
みんな早くやらなくちゃ
早くやらなくちゃと思っちゃうんです
やらなくちゃと思ってもできないんですよ
あれは妄想に時間かかりますからね
それで私の結論は カタツムリ
カタツムリを早く行けて押すと止まってしまうんです
これが社会でよく見られます
人はこの自分のスピードを変えられませんよ
個人のスピードは でも見る限り早くできるんですよ
第三者が見ると でもこれ早くさせることはできない
例えば ある人が料理しようと思ったら
先に卵を割るんですね
卵を割って探すんで 次どうしようかと
そこをどこかに置いておいて
次にもうジャガイモの皮を剥くことを始めるんです
そこでなんとか失敗しちゃって
手が振っちゃって あの卵を割った卵を入れたあれがもう落ちちゃう
それでもう床にもう卵だからね
やれやれ すぐそれ片付けなくちゃいけない
それ片付けちゃって それからまたジャガイモをやると
で それからまたと すごい時間かかるでしょうね
見る限り何やってるのかと
まずこれやって 次これやって
次これやって こうやって早くやりなさいと言いたい気分になるでしょうに
しかし カタツムリを押してみて下さい
止まってくれるんです
カタツムリというのはそんな生命ですよ
我々みんなそうなんです
自分の時間より早く行けと押しちゃうと
能率が減るんです 上がらないんです
だから立派な社長 課長
部長だったら この妄想を何とかしてやめてもらうようなことをした方がいいんです
そうすると自動的に早いんです
寝る時間を少なくすることなんです
それはそう言っちゃうと
このベッドで寝る時間じゃないんです
ものすごいもう起きて寝ているんだからね
妄想で 妄想の時間は寝る時間ですよ
機能しないんだからね
世間の時間 時間が遅いが
人間の心は断然早いんです
忙しいではなく 遅すぎ暇だと感じるべきところですよ
忙しいって言えない 言えないんです
人間な 本当に正気の人間なら
あー暇だ暇だ 退屈やと言わなくちゃいかんですよ
例えば料理作った もうもう味噌汁もご飯も炊いて
もうじゃがじゃき肉じゃがも作って卵焼きも作って多いだと
ああ まあ退屈や やることがなかったと
時間が余っていてしょうがないと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも逆なんです 忙しいと言うんです
しかし 空いていけない
忙しいと不満を言っているのです
個人が妄想に無駄な時間を増やして増やすのは問題点なのです
だから問題はそちらにあります
妄想に時間を浪費していること
浪費していないと誰も忙しいと言わない
逆に暇やと言うんです
退屈やと言うんです はい
次 それでこのちょっとこういうことで考えてみてください
世界と個人の時間のずれ
そこであのよく妄想する人の仕事ぶりと成果っていうのは
よく妄想すると心がこうやって自己回転で妄想して寝ているんです
この青い線で書いているのは心
人の心なんですね 心へ
世間のものの流れは一定で流れています
で ゴールは上あるんですよ
しかし 時間切れ この人はまだゴールに達してないんです
ゴールに達してないんだけど
かなりの距離は走ってるんですよ
かなりの距離走ってるんですよ
ぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐるぐる
でも世間はスーッと一直線で流れてるだけ
走ったのは走った そこら辺でくたびれているんです
しかし ゴールはものすごいほど遠い
これはたくさん妄想する人のケースなんです
はい 次 そこで妄想が普通な人間の仕事ぶりと成果
これもあの線の長さは測れませんだけど
同じなんです この青い線の長さは
これでわからないかもしれませんだけど
本当は同じ線書いてるんです
で 妄想は普通の人だったらそれまたたくさん走ってますよ
たくさん走ってますけど
まあそこそこゴールは見えるところに行ってるかも
ゴールはあっちであるのに
こちらでくたびれて死ぬと
でも世間は同じパターンで流れていく
はい 次 これは心 これは心
C の場合は 妄想が少ない人の仕事ぶりと成功
妄想がほとんど少ない場合は同じ速さで走るんだけど
前に進んでいるんです
心が それでゴールに達しているんです
成功者なんです 妄想もそれなりにするんだけど
だからって人生は失敗はしません
妄想が完全に消えるということはあり得ません
だからね 大体その人はゴールになります
忙しいとは言わない あの前のケースもBも忙しいと言うんです
C さんは忙しいと言わない
はい 次のこと もし人が妄想しないならばなんですよ
同じ速さの心なんです
そういう風に妄想はないんです
仕事をたくさんなり 今こちらへいくつ 5つ書いてますけど
仕事 5つ書いてますけど
さっさっさっさと全部やっちゃって
5つ成功しちゃうと  5つってことは
ただいい加減で数でチャートのために書いただけで
妄想しないと今やってる仕事よりも
まあ大体3倍は3倍4倍あたりはできると思います
今よりは今ギリギリやってる仕事よりも
で 私は時々このもう失礼な言葉ですけど
時々言うでしょうしね
私はあなた方 10人の仕事できるそうと
あるいは別にもう失礼に感じるかもしれませんだけど
なぜかというと 私は仕事にかかっちゃうとすぐやっちゃうんです
だから妄想に時間かからないんだから
早いだけのことで 能力あるっていうわけじゃないんです
日本語の文章を書く人は皆様に能力あるのは当たり前でしょうに
しかし 私の方が早いんです
日本語を知らない こうの何学こう
考古学 国語 国語も文学も日本語で全然勉強してないんです
自分の国で 私は文学は大嫌いで
ごまかしちゃったんです
なのに書こうとしちゃうと
誰が早いかと これぐらいさすがにすごい時間かかったと思いますか？だからだから打ち間違えとかありますけどね
指が遅いのでただイライラするんですよ
なんでこいつ遅い？コンピューターが次のそれなんでこれが遅いかと
だから心は先にすごく早いんですよ
それで遅くて遅くてもイライラするんです
だからこの妄想しないんで
その時は 一応これはこの妄想無視しないならばなんですよ
無視しないならば 今よりは結構仕事はできます
たくさんのことができるでしょうと
ということで だからこの人は忙しいと言うんじゃなくて
退屈やと言うんです たくさん仕事できたくてもあるわけないでしょ
たくさん仕事は世の中で
だからもう暇でたまらんんですよ
妄想しちゃうとこの暇は大事なんですよ
瞑想するために 悟るために
煩悩をなくすために時間が必要です
はいはい 続けます